now wide open mouth mouth don't cut
welcome back to the Julian podcast won't
go bad it's a beautiful sunny Southern
California day no it's not is gloomy
it's so cold is gloomy and cold cold was
relative we already had this
conversation don't come for me and no
it's not snowing all right but it's cold
I thought you were on the other end of
that argument I am the people are still
like oh you do need school 34 feet snow
all right my whole house is covered in
snow you big baby
my Big Brother's a penguin penguin arms
and knees
that's a cute ones are you rang thank
you I know they're not a sponsor this
week but it's the me Andy's one that
they sent me
it's so cute is it's a stormtrooper with
a disco ball pretty cute how much you
think it cost them to get that hot Star
Wars merch I know that's like a serious
collab hey guys get out of here oh no we
don't have a guess he's busy like
licking both of them right now oh he's a
creep and Bunny's here she's in her bed
we were you're gonna do some self-care
today it's gonna be a little bit pretty
maybe a little bit shorter of a podcast
a normal in there we don't sponsors
today so we decided stay and do whatever
we want
well we can say otherwise we wouldn't
choose those that's why responses are
great because they love us for us hey
but are they sick
no we're just gonna do a little
self-care delay Jenna had this idea that
we would do with self care cast don't
care Sunday because it's Sunday for us
or making this yes that's also why you
usually see us in our pajamas and
glasses and well to be fair I like live
in the yes glasses wait one glasses no I
mean for me okay you're not wearing
glass I call that was super heart cuz I
was like yeah if I have the choice I'm
always wearing my contacts and then
people are like Jenna every podcast
no we record at least in the last couple
months we've been recording on Thursdays
right as this week is a little extra
crazy with stuff going on so we weren't
able to so we're recording on Sunday but
this is for self-care it's time for
self-care we haven't really even gone
our lives back together like we've
mentioned in the past on a lot of
different platforms and podcasts and
streams we haven't been able to leave
both leave the house for longer than 30
minutes we've got to the point where
we're sort of at least for a temporary
situation we're having our trainer come
to our house and train us instead of us
going to the gym and if one of us has to
go kind enough to do that
he loves it it's a good gig he gets to
come and see dogs and train us he's fine
he likes it well it's you know he gets
to leave the gym for a little so it's a
little field trip so we've been doing
that and we've had a lot of visitors but
I would say close to close to 20 maybe
like 15 people have come to the house
and met bunny so she's doing well with
visitors just like a little brief update
but yeah we are very much glued to our
home he doesn't get to be on here today
he can be in my lap he's having a mommy
day I don't care about any of that
that's that's irrelevant he's not gonna
be on the case he's having a mom he's
gonna knock over the glass of water and
it's gonna ruin all of our equipment he
will do that quite literally not worth
ruining that okay if you're gonna you're
gonna make me choose between the Apollo
and Carmen I'm gonna have to think for a
little while okay cuz if he spills water
the things you just beat you didn't he
thought about biting me
he didn't why why do I support this
toxic relationship he's having a mommy
day I don't know what that means
and I don't want to know exactly what
that means you know exactly what a mommy
day is I need self-care now this is
stressing it's when one of them decides
that they're like glued to me all day
enough I need self-care I need a daddy
daddy needs a daddy day I'm gonna start
with this no no oh we have to introduce
everything no there's an order boy okay
yeah you can you can use the Jade ruler
if you'd like thank you so anyway
explain what this is
welcome to our self-care Sunday which is
made up as a thing so honestly self-care
Sunday that could be a thing sounds like
one of those things that people do well
it's like put nice things on your face
and then eat Chiti naughty food and play
some video games yeah I'm with your dog
so family I'm supposed to oh let the
stone do the work for you
so I was using that the other night on
stream and everyone was like what is
that what is that what are you doing
what's going on are you shaving your
face and I don't remember exactly why I
bought it like I've seen other people
use it and I'm like that looks cool but
like that's probably trash right let's
probably a gimmick like that
can't possibly do anything it's just a
jade stone on a little stick that you
roll on your face and I well to begin
with I bought a skincare fridge because
I saw Sophia Nygaard tweet about it and
I was like that is so extra that is so
cute but like I don't I don't think I
need that like I like skincare but I'm
not religious about it and I'm not very
good sometimes I just fall asleep you
know what I'm saying
but um Julian started wearing the little
under eye patches like a lot and he
really likes them so he was keeping them
in the cheese drawer in the refrigerator
so I was like okay now is the perfect
time I'm gonna just pull the trigger I'm
gonna do it it's ridiculous I don't care
it's not ridiculous and it's honestly
like a reasonable price for what you're
getting it's literally a mini fridge
yeah they have them in like different
price ranges and different sizes and I
also didn't know that people used little
refrigerators like that for breast milk
or like diabetes insulin and that kind
of thing there pretty practical for
things like that and they have you know
hook up so you could put it in your car
you know for people that like actually
need to travel with their medication
that's there's a lot of different
medical reasons for little refrigerators
like that the B shots I used to take
know what the B shots that I used to
give myself oh my god I hated those
Julie don't you don't need to make a
scene all I'm saying is those
to be refrigerated oh you're making a
whole scene right guys they were just
literally be complex shots okay well
they were amazing and I wish I got them
I'm getting nauseous just thinking about
it okay dude you literally literally
like you can go at Whole Foods so give
you B shots but it's just like vitamin B
do they do it
some of them I've seen it they're like
come in Tuesday for a B shot you know if
someone comes in yeah yep he would give
himself B shots looks like you want to
be shot like [ __ ] no no oh I probably
offered you once and then you made this
exact scene so I was like I'm never
offering you again and then I also like
never I just did it I kept to myself but
it's just like I'm not here to you know
make a scene about it it just felt
really good to help recovery you but you
could let go to a doctor and gonna be
shot or you could literally not throw up
stop stop
David self-care day don't throw enough
throwing up okay I was going through the
comments of last week's podcast for
ideas and eight eight out of ten
comments were about me scream vomiting
and how funny that is and frankly it's
not funny because I'm vomiting and it
sucks I saw way more comments up where
people like my husband also scream
vomits or like I've seen it got that
actually thank you for telling me that
your loved ones and roommates also do
that because now I feel less crazy
someone said that their roommate sounds
like they're birthing a demon when they
vomit so that made me feel a lot better
about myself so shouts out to the person
who birthed the demon when they vomit
your normal to just like me anyway no
more vomiting anyways we bought a
skincare fridge which seemed don't oh my
god don't all right you done touching
stuff you're gonna break something so we
bought a skincare fridge because Julian
liked likes doing those little under eye
patches and he started keeping them in
the cheese drawer so I was like this is
a good opportunity it's a perfect excuse
to get Julian or skincare yeah just you
know project on me but I was half lying
because I think it's fun too so
so then so then I got a skincare fridge
for you know all of the skincare that I
then purchased to put in it because I
had used all of mine and I was like I
should go Jade roller because now we
have a little fridge so then it's gonna
be cold you know otherwise it was like
okay that feels incredible do it while
it's cold right now yeah it feels really
good oh wait that already went good
oh you're sweet I am so then I was
looking on Amazon for a Jade roller like
no idea what the price range is or you
know whatever and it's a little
confusing cuz I'm like I don't get it
there's a there's like one that's like a
hundred bucks some are like 20 and some
are like five dollars I'm like okay
obviously there must be a deviation and
quality here of what's going on so I
just did the best that I could define
one but I was reading reviews and
comments and people were saying that it
helped with like blood flow and with
high blood but like obviously I don't
know any of this but that they have high
blood pressure and because it like
drains your lymphatic system that it
helped with you know circulation and
that kind of suffer people were saying
all kinds of crazy things that it helped
them with and I was like okay I just
wanted to roll it on my face you know
because it feels good but yeah this one
I got I think for around like twenty
dollars yeah reminds me of my first
thought was like went in between rounds
and like a boxing around my fight the
cut man has like the little metal slab
that he's like reducing the swelling
with I'm like rubbing it onto their face
that's what that feels like a much in a
much less intense and more mild for me
well I just I don't know if it's like I
Amazon is very confusing I don't know if
it's real Jade or whatever I bought this
one because it doesn't have a jade
handle and a lot of people are saying
that the Jade ones with handles that are
made of jade snap in half sometimes oh
okay I'm out what is next we have this
stuff which is literally magic drunk
elephant yeah so I bought drunk elephant
products because again people were
saying really cool things and reviews
that it was really great and there's I
don't know whatever
there's no essential oils or like that
kind of stuff that can sometimes be
problematic for people's skin so it's
like I don't have sensitive skin or
really anything but
if somebody loves it I also want to love
it you know so this is a TLC to carry
baby facial and this is like first of
all on the website it says only
available in the United States which
means some level of this aah a and BHA
is probably too high to sell in other
countries okay whatever be safe
I don't know that yeah but it's like
it's sort of like a chemical peel almost
so oh okay do you think how do I put it
put a thin layer on your face it's like
a like a lotion and then it's gonna
sting what it's chemical don't put it
near your eyes okay Finn I already did
no generally don't put it near your eyes
we should have brought like a mirror up
here I can't see anything we're gonna
have to help each other oh that's what
friends do someone said it was so nice
to hear about your friendship retreat
retreat retreat is such a platonic word
no no one ever goes on a romantic
retreat it's either like a work retreat
or like a work retreat you calling a
vacation a corporate event that's what
people are saying they were saying it
was nice to hear about your friendship
retreat okay so what is it supposed to
do okay just leave it on your face a
little bit for about 20 minutes 20
minutes oh my god self-care takes time
you can't rush through it self-care to
me is doing things so fast that I can do
other things you can't just do things
fast and life see that you can do other
things Julian you gotta take your time
so it literally says like on this
packaging like why is it smell like that
so make sure that you sort of build up
your skin's tolerance to other haze and
phas cuz it's gonna sting like it makes
your face all red it's intense you know
what I'm saying fam I feel like I'm
having a reaction to this I'm sure you
are honestly okay so I have this water
that's about it sorry thing I just said
up here Julian when we first started
dating Julian's the first and only
person I've ever seen when he's done
eating
he will take whatever napkin paper cloth
or anything around him dunk it in some
water and clean off his hands and mouth
with it I've never seen anything how is
that weird that's that's like as far as
like the things that I do that you would
be weirded out by that I wasn't weirded
out at all it's just like do you do that
like chat chat in the comments let me
know into it if you guys do I know I'm
like literally streaming 24 hours these
days if you do that I mean I feel like
I've saw my dad do it when I was young
and I was like oh okay that's so that's
how he cleans like his mouth and his
hands after he's done eating so he's not
a mess so I do it now you just take a
little napkin
well good it's very easy and convenient
you don't have to go to the bathroom you
can be first to check out the dessert
menu or you could eat with utensils and
not get it all over your face
oh it would be no ninis perfect never
gets food on her face oh but I wipe it
off with the napkin I don't feel the
need have you ever put off with water I
usually like wearing something like
makeup or something on my face I don't
want it just like oh that's how a white
ring around that's why it's weird to you
because you don't want to like wipe the
makeup off for me that's not a concern I
just like like if you're gonna if you're
gonna wipe something off of your face
mm-hmm with a dry napkin versus a
slightly dampened one I'm choosing the
depth one every time because it's way
more effective I don't disagree
Julian used dampened napkin it was super
effective that's me at dinner that is
you at dinner I just like you know in
movies when people during a scene they
would walk to a bathroom and like splash
water and their faces I'm like yeah but
what about your moisturizer and like
your makeup I can't just go to the
bathroom and splash water on my face
then after my face is gonna be dry like
what the hell these people be splashing
their faces will water would they be
doing why movies be like have you ever
done that you ever just like been
released
style to go to the bathroom and splash
of never water never
why is that a movie cliche it's the same
reason why in movies people start
sentences with look or listen no one
starts sentences like that
listen yeah like no one says gotta find
the node to the safe
yeah no I'm every time someone says
listen to start a sentence in a movie
I'm like oh yeah that's right I'm
watching a movie this isn't real
so is that on the writers this is a
writer thing that someone made up on
everyone it's on the writer an actor
what's the actor supposed to do ignore
that part of the line do their job
matters into their own hands I think
that's a great way to get fired that's a
great way to stand out like Julian
there's dialogue and all you have to do
is just say it you know what you fired
okay see if it sounds weird but it's not
people totally say that yeah but not the
way they do in movies yeah I think
you're right there's like movie words
that and that like are set in so many
movies especially like the poorly
written ones that immediately make me
feel like I'm watching a movie let's get
out of here
yeah isn't that the most said line in
movies let's get out of here yeah oh my
god we've hacked the mainframe that's a
good one
enhance I think that's specific seen any
good movies lately Julian um no I want
to see John wick I haven't seen that yet
where are you I don't you baiting me
yeah I'm kidding
well movie dad what we haven't seen any
movie oh no I want to see John wick
though I was supposed to see with a
friend but never never did but I hear
they're making a fourth one so already
yeah well they they like announced that
uh I guess pretty much the third was so
successful that it's like my favorite
action series ever I love it I watched
like 20 minutes of it and was grossed
out by blood of the first one even that
gory it's too much for me it's like I'd
rather watch you give yourself a be shot
no you wouldn't
I can guarantee you wouldn't you're
right I'm mine on the scale of like like
action movies and with the ones that are
like gory and bloody and it's like that
ranks really low which explains my
tolerance levels really low yeah I guess
so I don't like it
I just love I love the way they do that
serious I feel like it's shot really
cool and like they leave there's so much
substance in the action scenes that
there's not like you don't even have to
feel like you're watching a million cuts
you just kind of watch the action play
out and the gunplay is really great and
there's a lot of jujitsu in it too which
is really cool
accurate jujitsu accurate jujitsu Keanu
trained hard for for that series he
trained a lot of jujitsu that's one of
your pet peeves though right when people
are doing bad jujitsu in movies or or
not we're not using it at all
when it would be the easiest route and
any given fight most given fights that
our movies have do you have an example
um no I have an example of Scarlett
Johansson the Black Widow is at her
mm-hmm yeah so she did like this
I forget what movie it's been so long
since I've watched a Marvel movie I luck
if you want to yell let me go ahead I
haven't seen any my haven't watched like
the Avengers and forever but there was
one scene I think I was watching with
Mark where I think she did like she used
rubber guard or something and it took me
so off guard because I was like a Marvel
movie really you know yeah it was like
it was like one of those big epic fights
in the street where everything's getting
destroyed and she just decides to use
rubber god I was like wait a minute
that's crazy but yeah I don't know I
feel like when when someone's just like
on the ground and they're just like
getting over what should they do in that
situation not do that grab one of their
shirt lapels do something I don't know
kick not kick scream scream would work
scream is good tell them a knock-knock
joke there's not enough time for that
and it's too loud these are all of my
defenses against no no tickle that's
your defense you tickle it's legal you
even yourself said that it's legal not
that there's any rules if you're
fighting some
on the street there are no rules but
yeah you wouldn't go into a jiu-jitsu
class and tickle someone while you're
training so you're saying the coach
wouldn't give me a stripe on my belt for
tickling and defeating him he would show
you the door
well I could take down a black belt no
problem with some good tickles I mean if
you really work on your tickling
technique tic-tac then you know like if
I beat your coach who's a black belt
like a third degree black belt he's more
than a third degree whatever yet you
understand what I'm trying to say you
wouldn't why would you think that's even
possible with tickling yeah with
tickling okay then what's the question
if you did that then what what color
belt do I guess no way damn it Dean you
get a rainbow stripe for all your
tickles thank you
anyway back to my point I don't know how
we got here what would you point judge
my point as John wick is a really great
series and I'm excited to see the third
and eventually the fourth - can I take
this off my face it hurts
it hasn't been 20 minutes it's just been
20 minutes Julian literally hasn't okay
what's that
how much time we get uh what are you
pointing at there's nothing there Oh the
monitor that's monitoring our audio for
the podcast
oh yeah like 23 minutes maybe in a
couple of minutes you can take it off
it's fine I'm in no rush does it sting
yes
are you okay yeah it's weirdly like
making my throat hurt are you allergic
to it probably is your throat hurt at
all like not even like a little tingle
or something no why is my throat always
hurt you're allergic to a lot of snide I
know I don't think so
how do you know if you're dying I mean
slowly every day yeah but not right now
not like all it was wise yeah damn okay
what's your what's your favorite movie
that you've seen recently cuz I know you
watch a lot of movies I've seen a lot of
movies that I hate recently what well
when we're in Hawaii we watched paul
blart mall cop
that is such a good move actually I was
enjoying myself cuz it's so funny and me
me at this point like I wanted to see
what the hype was about was so good I
want to watch the second one now I do
too paul blart to the streets right yeah
oh my god too furious I think it's such
a good shitty movie
it would mean a lot like so many plot
holes it's terrible it's so good yeah it
was a good it put me in a good boat yeah
which is more than I can say for a lot
of films because I I just don't like a
lot of movies
yeah it puts you in a good mood just
like stuck on you that puts me in a
great mood that put me in a frustrated
mood because you can fit the hyping it
up so much and it just it really was
that bit I have a question I do like
stuck on you though okay because it's
pretty good and because you only know
share from stuck on yous but I did like
stuck on you I'll give you that what if
I decided to not do anything for the
next like 21 days and only watch stuck
on you on repeat would you be okay with
that
first of all I would call your mom and I
would say come get your boy he really
needs you right now so I'm just going on
I don't know how to help I really like
it
I would I would do that for what you're
asking
yeah reason that's my version of a
mental breakdown is this like a mr.
beefs YouTube video yeah something like
that
a couple years ago yeah you just learned
jacksFilms Twitter third thread
something like that right every day I
watched stuck on you it's just such a
great movie so many different dimensions
to it something about this conversation
really isn't self-care Sunday to me all
right let's give XSL fair I'm sorry this
is this is more like frustrating Fridays
mm-hmm all right you can or mindless
mondays or topless Tuesday's okay
Kermit's always on top was Tuesday he
never wears
that boy always naked are we WAP or we
whoppin yeah it's just wipe it off god
okay
why are you like mad at permit like he's
gonna knock over the water and get it on
the equipment when you're allowed to
dunk your washcloth in there 11 times
hello you're gonna scare bunny dude even
though that washcloth looks filthy
I swear that it's clean me at every
guest that's ever stated our house we
should just get new washcloths yeah
well I feel like there's a threshold
when you like use a towel or something
with makeup if you don't wash it like
fast enough after it sort of just kind
of like stays there maybe I was doing my
laundry
the washcloths that have stains are
literally just like makeup [ __ ] yeah in
hair dye and all kinds of stuff okay how
do people just be having really clean
towels you know I feel cared for alright
put on a mask of your choice hello kitty
I actually got those in Japan see the
price tag is in Japanese right there
this one oh yeah I guess they're
probably expired that was a long time
ago
wait are they expired I don't know is it
gonna be like rotten egg even if there
was an expiration date on I can't read
it the whole back is in Japanese dude
what you don't know don't hurt you right
something like that what mama don't know
can't hurt her what movie is that from
well movie is that from it sounds like
an Adam Sandler film yep almost there
sounds like the waterboy who's the
waterboy oh that's a cute one is it on
backwards
alright so if you want to use the Jade
roller and enroll any of the envious
skin it's right here whenever you do a
sheet mask it like just hangs off your
beard oh there's two and each one wasn't
listening I'm so sorry oh god I feel
like they should maybe they probably do
okay Julian they should make half sheet
masks for people with fears oh my god
what shark tank where are you at that is
brilliant it's not brilliant they
probably already make them and why would
a company just start making half sheet
masks when a company that already makes
them could just add a half sheet mask
what are you doing prototyping so do you
remember that company that was on Shark
Tank that was like lace face or
something and it just went around your
head so that it would stay oh my god
that's so much better
why don't you look it up it probably
exists oh my god and you look more like
a superhero like Batman I look like
Batman I need to talk into my mic I'm
not talking into my mic today oh this
feels so much better I don't feel like
it's just like dangly mess on my beer
that won't stick to my face this is
actually a really cute sheep mask I
think oh damn you look [ __ ] cared for
my dude
thanks my dude my guy oh this is a
Sunday right here this is a Sunday stuff
how do I look you look great thank you
very kawaii thank you when we are in
Japan I learned the word kawaii cuz I
hadn't heard it before or paid attention
to what it meant I guess but then I
started saying oh that's so cool I and
Kauai means scary but kawaii is cute
yeah it's a common mistake Japan saying
this is scary also scary
okay don't all Julian this feels good
how does your face feel my face feels
goddamn bangin I actually hey it's not
touching your skin anywhere don't Park
it me you look like a superhero
Julian you fight crime do you this [ __ ]
don't know what Pangea I'm here to save
the day unless it's gonna take longer
than like two hours cuz I gotta be
somewhere later okay where you gotta be
what the racquetball court I got a game
schedule what's your favorite form of
self-care Julian this is one of mine
this is actually really nice I would say
my favorite form of self-care is
obviously food like food is my self-care
City right it's the capital of self-care
country mm-hmm so that includes just
eating yeah mainly just eating sometimes
I actually weirdly like to like buy
myself a new pair of shoes like online
like I'll there's like some sites that
all browse and be like oh you know like
most of them are just like ultra boost
or something like a different color that
I don't have but I just like a pair of
shoes some food I'm pretty easy office
playing in the background you know a
good shower there's a nice bit of
self-care for me ah cleaning weirdly I
know this sounds weird but like if there
are things that are kind of a mess
around the house or like in
a closet or wherever that I feel like I
can just kind of tidy up that is
self-care for me like if I clean the
whole kitchen I feel so good afterwards
it's not fun I don't enjoy it but I
enjoy what it feels like afterwards so
that's kind of self-care for me
[Music]
organizing all my camera gear right like
cleaning out all the footage off the
cards and cleaning my cameras and the
sensors and organizing things like that
that's fun are you looking at me like
that I'm just listening okay my face
masks on
sometimes all no that's it that's all I
do what about you I like to do nothing I
know I think we know that I know I like
to call my dogs and do nothing
yeah that's a good version of self-care
I'm gonna put this wet washcloth on
camera no don't do that Jim Oh poor
babies having a mommy day
I'm sorry Kermie you didn't deserve a
wet washcloth no you did it I'm sorry
yeah I really wonder if this exists okay
why don't you look it up like a half
sheet mess yeah a half sheet mask sheet
mask for beards sheet mask full beards
imma look it up tell us what you find
half sheet masks are just like the top
of your face
they definitely exist I've seen them
before mask for beards sheet masks for
beards nope I'm not seeing anything
doesn't exist what about a half sheet
mask I searched that youssef on nothing
found nothing they definitely exist I
mean I'm not gonna like do a deep dive
on Google right now I'll look later but
I mean I mean I'm sure we'll figure it
out if it exists regardless we're
pitching it on Shark Tank I already
booked us next week okay so this is the
prototype we're working with right now I
don't think you can pitch someone else's
product ripped in half to each their own
I think you can what are your sales
200 million dollars last year were
projected to do 400 this year see I can
say numbers oh that's all you got a deal
you can't lie
listen I'll con every single one of
those shark except Robert Herjavec
because he won't invest wait are we back
to flamin Robert like respect my father
or something yeah well my face feels
good I'm gonna put some oil on oh you're
done yeah because look at my face is all
pink and red this is this is no joke
that's some real is quitting part of
your self-care I'm just kidding oh my
god what is this no that's it's a little
virgin marula luxury facial oil yeah
nourishing balance I really like drunk
elephant I like oh my god but there's
it's so expensive
am i glowing I buy the little ones
what is this lotion but I did buy a big
one of like some of the other stuff but
I didn't buy this one in the big version
so I just have a little one for now look
how pink and red my face is it's a good
day to do this cuz then tomorrow I'd be
looking normal
you know yeah your your skin is I think
more sensitive sometimes than mine like
to stuff like this because we just did
the same what is it the mask the peel
mask a chemical thing whatever and my
face is is my face red a little bit but
you look really cute yeah I do
I'm kidding no your your face is like
it's clearly reacting irritated as hell
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] but do you look like
yourself caring I look to have some
water on my face
wow that must be so nice what what you
lack in sensitive skin you make up for
in sensitive eyes and allergies so oh I
have a lot of sense
sensitive allergies that really weirdly
pop up and I haven't I still don't know
like what I'm allergic to
yeah that's the most frustrating part
cuz you'll wake up so what if that's
normal and you do that thing where you
go all like 11 times in a row and I just
quote favor you okay but you could never
tell which are allergic to what you
isolate certain things yeah is that like
that must be a normal thing where people
like have seasonal or otherwise like
regular allergies and they're like yeah
I'm just allergic or I have daily
allergies and I take like a daily
allergy pill for it but I don't know
exactly what I'm allergic to
yeah but that's the thing even if you
did like an allergy test and you found
out what you were allergic to regardless
of what it is you would still have to
take like whatever you take is it you
claritin yeah but then you'd be able to
avoid that one thing I should do an
allergy test or could you though if it
was something in the air yeah I mean
well it provided the answer is like okay
it's dust like yes you could take
measures to like dust more or vacuum or
or whatever but if it was like you can't
roll around the grass then I wouldn't
roll around on the grass if you want a
grass allergy though it would show up on
your skin biology if I lay around in the
grass if I roll around I get like ridin
high v yeah that's why you don't see me
amongst being an adult who doesn't roll
around in grass that's why you don't
seem to roll around in grass I love
rolling in the grass okay why don't you
I do I don't see you do it wait so if
you're allergic to grass does it show up
on your skin as well as like give you an
inch you throw or just a skin it's more
of the skin for me it's more of a skin
the throat thing like when I when I have
to make that like itchy throat noise or
I'm like my ear you know like that thing
that's like I feel like something that's
in the air that I'm by the way I'm a
doctor so you know if it's like dust or
pollen or whatever that's like airborne
that's when I get like that what we
recently just changed our air
conditioning filter in the house and
before we did it it was really bad
because i think the AC
like pushing out all this like dust and
allergens it and so when we got the new
filter immediately made a difference
like the next night I was like holy [ __ ]
I feel good I don't have any allergies
like that I've never had to just like
take a allergy medication like that it's
frustrating so I see you have to do it
like a lot yeah I have that an asthma
like I don't know it's all just kind of
like what I've dealt with forever it
seems normal
it's kind of crazy that you don't have
it I'd like sports asthma like I had an
inhaler for a while and then sort of
grew out of it hmm so that's there was
the opposite for me well it happened for
me and then I grew back into it
No yeah like like when I was a kid I had
allergy or asthma and I would have to
take it every day and then high school
and like some of college I sort of
outgrew it to where I like if I forgot
my inhaler wasn't a big deal I can still
work out or whatever no you know I now I
need it and it's not like if I run I
can't breathe without it it's like I
start wheezing a little bit it's just
like that that wheezing feeling well I
still wheeze should I be using an
inhaler well if it's an asthma wheeze
then yeah there's different types of
wheezing I would say but there's a
distinct one from when you have wheezing
to be funny
wheezing to get out of doing the
exercise that you don't feel you're good
at doing things to get out of exercise I
I okay first of all I never get out of
exercises I just joke about getting out
of exercises I try to barter my trainer
yes yeah well he's onto your [ __ ] I
still do them I still do everything I
don't complain shut up just do it but
like first I make a joke and barter just
to see ya
come on I'm good at negotiating you are
sometimes you just claim that your legs
don't work though that doesn't really
it's not believable yes it is yeah no
yeah no you said you walk into the gym
and he says okay I warm up do on the
treadmill and then you say I'm so tired
from being born
stop why it's true I'm tired from being
born it was a traumatic experience that
I'm still trying to deal with hello I
think everyone can relate you're sick
how am i sick I'm just kidding you cute
oh thanks are you doing the Jade roller
yeah yeah I'm Jade rolling that Mayola
oil into my face oh um okay try yeah in
a second I wouldn't I'm curious to know
what you guys do for self-care because I
want to get some ideas for self-care so
maybe self-care Sunday's we can add some
stuff to our routine routines routine is
that plural for routines EA's fancy
rotund I rotund I what are you gonna eat
today since it's Sunday and that's such
a big part of your self-care I don't
know I'm gonna take care of myself with
some Carl's jr. you know yeah we're
we're still dude go on of a Burger King
we're waiting for you do to get that
impossible burger I'm waiting patiently
Burger King is my father I just want to
try it do they put flour on their fries
at Burger King or no no I think
McDonald's is one of the only like main
chain fast-food restaurants to do that
right and maybe jack-in-the-box but I
don't really eat there ever
but yeah Burger King and the impossible
burger is like something I'm holding my
breath for and waiting very patiently
for I try that but they're not you have
gluten-free bun so you cool just a
lettuce wrap I love a lettuce wrap
burger I like one in a bun I like a
lettuce wrap burger a because
gluten-free buns mostly suck and be
because you eat the whole burger and
you're like I don't really that like
feel that horrible right now I like
feeling horrible okay cool okay Julianne
uh I was gonna wipe this off for you you
you don't want to just like to later
from my face to your face too late I
already cared for myself
it's your this is like can get bacteria
and stuff on ur then you're just gonna
jam it into your skin Oh
bacteria okay let's see don't Jade roll
your glass
you got to go side to side I think
that's what the little diagram said okay
you know and that's exactly why people's
Jade rollers break because they let
their boyfriends use them for one second
you did it way too hard
boyfriends be like your skin feel great
I honestly want to just hang out in that
makeup fridge because it's so nice oh
it's so cold I want to put some eye so
the eye patches that I like I I still
don't know what the name of the thing is
I have to figure out the name of the
ones I like because the ones we have are
like slimy and they fall off and then
the other ones don't stay cold but the
other ones that are like perfect so
maybe on the next episode of self-care
cast I'll have those eye patches here
and we can do like the next the next
kind of group of stuff that we have
added to our routines but I'm gonna look
for those and get those because those
like when you wake up especially after
you drink the night before when you wake
up what when you drink the night before
and you wake up and you're like a little
puffy a little tired a little hungover
whatever you put some of those from the
fridge under your eyes oh my god you're
you're a new man I feel like they don't
do that much for me
they really don't well rolling the stone
on my face you know I'm I'm enjoying it
but it doesn't do a ton for me either
I feel like after like during it feels
like nice and cold and good but then
after like a few minutes later I'm like
oh my face feels kind of good mmm I feel
that way about the patches mmm you wanna
fight yeah okay physically verbally or
telepathically two out of those three
are problematic
let's telepathically fight ready three
two one damn I just got [ __ ] up well
Kim is glowing I know
I hope my skin comes down in a little
bit cuz it's so I look like a strawberry
you're cute strawberry thank you I'm
thank you guys for spending your your
time with us and listening to the
podcast watching the podcast and
hopefully maybe you also did some
self-care well listen
right that's a good episode to do some
self-care tree or you you didn't do some
self-care and you used for stressing
over a paper that you have to do or
studying or getting yelled at by your
mom who just won't quit
hopefully you're in your pajamas though
because it's better to be stressed in
your pajamas but if you're not in your
pajamas that also probably means you're
on your way to work which means it's
good because you have a job and you know
you're you're doing it's Monday okay oh
wait it's a holiday Hey
getting your pajamas bucket it is a
holiday but that's an American holiday
yeah so if you're in Australia you might
still be gonna work Australia so don't
want your pajamas you might get fired
and if you get fired don't tell them
it's our fault actually blame us what
are they gonna blame Julian in
particular blame me just blame me okay
well thank you guys for hanging out
we'll see you guys next week for another
podcast
with less just nonsense and stuff on the
table because this is this is a mess but
we'll see you guys next week have a good
week we'll be on twitch all week long
we're actually gonna be playing a fun
story game this week oh yes 9pc shat the
bed janice pc shat the bed it died it
died literally said goodbye cruel world
and then died just died PS you broke so
because due to the circumstances of one
pc completely breaking on us we've
decided we're excited to play a new uh
story game together not because you know
we planned that outside of our computer
breaking but it's okay we're gonna be
playing a fun story game it's called
life is strange too we played the first
version of it a couple years ago on
stream and it was I think a pretty big
hit with you guys but we played the
second one for a little bit and people
were mad at us for being mad at it so
we're gonna be mad at we're gonna be
invested no we did not play the second
one there was a there was like a 1.5
that we played the second one is
something we have not touched well yeah
we did play like this like the next
installment of it and we were kind of
[ __ ] on it but regardless we're
gonna do that
when I into it yeah so join us on Twitch
we'll be there and if we don't see you
there we'll see you next week on the
podcast that you guys were hanging out
we'll see ya be good like
[Music]